[Music]
near kid University Falls around you
you think that you'll always be
protected and cared for then one day you
realize that's not true
because when you're alone as a kid
the monster see you is weaker you don't
even know they're getting closer till
it's too late
my grandfather thinks this town is
cursed
that all the bad things that happen in
this town or because of one thing and
they will think I saw something
a clown yeah I saw him too what happens
when another Georgie goes missing us are
you just gonna pretend it isn't
happening like everyone else in this
town yeah just stick together
but
[Music]
how are we feeling for staying to school
you nervous it's really exhausted
hopeless and I don't enjoy the things
that I once loved where are you getting
this from this is all wash commercial
obviously there's this really sweet guy
in my yoga class I believe it separated
for five months girls it's my birthday
[Music]
so I'd like to offer to buy you drinks
okay by the way I'm definitely old
enough to drink alcohol meet you
obviously I just always act out on my
birthday it's like my own personal near
Zoo I just feel like not just reel it
back to normal
did you wash this I did but only because
I was doing a load and I've been up
since 5:30 hurry up you guys
what are you guys doing home I thought
Nana was taking your school you're
acting weird
oh my god thank you very much for
everything
mrs. and you are
I like them namaste I'm teddy but
they're dead broke so I thought they
could stay here stay here try looking at
this as something that could be sort of
exciting okay guys let's just do our
best not to grab each other style right
uh-oh she grabbed that and closed down
until it I don't know your ex but he
must be some kind of maniac do I let you
slip through his hands
you know I'm 40 right I knew that like
boo ballpark oh my god tell me you see
em tail what are you doing here oh my
god I just can't think straight is that
one of
[Music]
did you tie dad about your play please
stay for it daddy when is it again next
exciting I miss my family best fixes you
make a decision about your life when
you're 25 years old you think that's not
like a good life decision for the rest
of your life seem to be handling
everything really well
okay let's eat
[Music]
it's gonna be good bye good night
okay we spend all our time here I want
to make a paradise she redid all of it
very less detail
well she breathed life back into every
room happy please coming hello he's a
stranger we're just gonna let him sleep
in our house hello hello did you know he
had a wife he has pictures of humanists
language what were you doing in their
luggage god help you
[Music]
come here to see me open the door to new
people new ideas you're given you give
me the kid it's just never enough
[Music]
[Applause]
that day on the beach it changed you you
want revenge what you think you're gonna
jump from cell-to-cell taking out
terrorists for starters yeah our people
here like your agenda Mitch I know
exactly what to do with you what do I
need to know about this guy he's a
warrior one of the best I've ever known
some bad things I knew now you want to
go kill terrorists am i right out there
it's about the mission not about you
sigh cement stroke right here like this
is testing through the roof you need
focus is off the charts
I've seen off to church before not like
this you think you're special never ever
let it get personal what is it you think
we do here kill people who need to be
killed we got a problem six days ago 15
kilos of plutonium went missing look at
this it can't be him it's him Irene its
ghost ycs guy half to you something
personal something
everything he did I thought about it
there's a milk inflate
got 48 hours Istanbul
I trusted you you should have come for
me eliminate the target yes sir
[Music]
this whole thing is just a mean son
entry you know this is just a beginning
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hey mom can we talk about dorba Tom so
when you guys got together was dad
always an evil okay well here it is I
got sucked up we have so many plans he
was swim bishop he said he wanted to
conquer the world I thought it was a
figure of speech but if I had never met
Garmadon I would have never had you a
true ninja knows when to fight and when
to play in the shadows unbelievable
Garmadon
Lloyd that's right and it's Lloyd
dad it's okay Lloyd nobody's parents are
perfect yeah but I feel like there's
more to Garmadon that I need to know to
understand your future you must go back
to your ninja roots your dad was a ninja
- Lloyd you hear that we don't waken the
unstoppable beast
be healthier are you ready to risk your
life for ninja go ninja go
I haven't felt this good in a long time
no noise are you okay yeah yeah I think
I think it's my arm is it bad I want to
look a scale of 1 to 10 to help that is
it oh I'd say it's about a seven-point
arm ripped off this film is not yet
rated well from the Kings montañés shop
in London maybe you've heard of us
today marks the beginning of a new age
but I'm gonna show you to the Kingsmen
kata for a bit of a save the world
situation here
welcome to statesman is your American
cousins will be working side massage
let's get started
we've got brains skills skipping-rope
[Music]
- lasso whatever
[Music]
it's very American yeah it is
[Music]
manners maketh man do you know what that
means listen up this young lady here is
running a marathon for bringing a
women's hospital
so skip around Estella and Tony - good
cause
I'm gonna be there at the finish line
Flay I'm gonna make a big sign for you
hasn't shown up for anything then he
shows up there was explosion and you
legs the gone bro
welcome all is it good to be back
talking to you what are you doing dancin
[Music]
tryin to make a hero out of me you need
to tell your family what's going on with
you I can't do this I can't I can't I
can't do it this is the first time
you're in this week and you had three
appointments you just have to show us I
showed up for you you remind me of my
son he died helping you made me feel
like I should help my son and for that I
am grateful you're grateful
[Music]
we showed the world that they can't
break us no matter what the hell they
doing
there was this time in the hospital when
I just want to give up look at busted
straw and now I just wanna live I just
wanted people to see how amazing my son
us I'm gonna walk I'm gonna walk with
you inside yeah
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
hello you're a recap le Jun Bobby Bobby
Riggs listen I had a great idea male
chauvinist pig vs. hairy leg feminists
no offense you're still a feminist right
I'm a tennis player who happens to be a
woman by the way I shaved my legs We are
privileged tennis fans to have the great
Billie Jean King word is you are a
renegade women should be paid and
respected equally I admire what you guys
are doing you're offering the men's
Leonard eight times what you're offering
the women's winner the men are simply
more exciting to watch it's just biology
I am NOT saying that women don't belong
on the course would pick up the balls
otherwise oh my god you know what I'm
doing I'm cooking I'm cooking there's a
single thing I don't hate it but Bobby
Riggs I'm in thousand dollars any woman
who can beat Bobby Riggs be out there
and don't you have the nerve
call Bobby Tom it's on so ladies what do
you want whatever I feel I can't act on
it there's too much it's a
business sports you name it the very top
it's a man's world five DMV Bobby Riggs
he's never gonna let it go you're alive
in three I'm gonna be the best so that
way I can really one change things when
we dare to one a little bit more just a
little bit of what you got that's what
you can't stand ladies and gentlemen put
the shell back is chauvinism you can
talk all you like dinosaurs can't play
tennis
I'm done talking us fight the battle
you've all been waiting to see the
battle of the sexes this is a United
States Drug Enforcement Agency we are
ordering insolence hi boys let's land
my name is Barry seal that's for the
damage for your sister
hey little darling and you're back some
of this [ __ ] really happened you never
saw me come for your class in the Civil
Air Patrol pilot like you shouldn't be
flying busses welcome to Miami
welcome to Bakersfield haven't you ever
wanted something more Barry you should
be serving your country Lucy hey we need
you to deliver stuff for us oh this is
legal if you're doing up for the good
guys
very seals it goddamn genius you are an
airline pilot berry that's how you
support this family is it gonna be good
for us this is how illegal you trust me
we're expanding operation ferry
Roscoe dug this up in the backyard there
Bill's blown around everywhere I'll rake
it up in the morning y'all know and
caddies have more trunk space than any
other car again each and every one of
you to caddy for your troubles
ja I'm gonna walk out of here - I
already damn thing any wonder you can do
about it boy should have taken a cash
I was working for the CIA the DEA and
Pablo Escobar McKinney and Tuscaloosa
that's 1,500 kilos are in one go get it
done
[Music]
do you have plans tonight do you want to
have fun with me later
Courtney Holmes I have mildly surprised
by offer except death midnight basements
of little see what's going on I would
like you to stop my heart you give it
one minute and then you bring me back
okay now is the point where you say it's
all a joke
[Music]
what happens to us after we die the only
way to find out is to see for ourselves
we could document that experience to see
a white light it was more like pure
energy
how is she playing the piano now it's
like her brain's been rewired I'm going
next charging 200 it's a good day to die
[Applause]
everyone I touched today I'm gonna heat
say how wait three minutes Dan yelling
did too what can I say
Oh competitive I'm going next five
minutes seven minutes
no one's ever come back from that
[Music]
was it all fun
is there anything disturbing something
isn't happening to us I'm going courtesy
maybe we open the door
[Music]
she's not stabilizing this experiment
needs to end right now
[Music]
I told you this wasn't about discovery
Hornets I do not know the decided facts
which show up and start coming us down
[Music]
[Music]